hello and welcome to another video my
name is David Mansour and I'm here today
again with Luca lamb fat yellow hey Luca
ok so today we're going to be speaking
about something that I think is really
really interested in as always and that
is pronunciation in a foreign language
now Luca you know many people compliment
you on the way in which you pronounce
foreign languages and you're often
mistaken for a native speaker now I know
that there are lots of people out there
that are wondering if this is something
that they too can achieve or if you have
talent for it so I'm going to let you
lead this one and let you leave this one
and tell me you know how is it possible
that how has it been possible for you to
develop the pronunciation that you have
in your foreign languages ok well first
of all I would like to say that
pronunciation is kind of a big word you
have to distinguish between intonation
and pronunciation like slightly
different things
uh-huh I would say that pronunciation is
how we pronounce in words the intonation
is that how we up to our whole sentences
and so that's a very important thing you
know to start with what I do Norway I
pay attention I think that while talent
plays a role
I believe that you have to develop a way
to pay attention to small details and
you know when you listen to a language
and I believe that a lot of people get
lost or just to have problems you know
have difficulties developing a good
pronunciation because they just think at
the beginning from the very beginning
they just think that
it's not very important so they say we
have to go for grammar and and words
first and then we can develop and work
on our pronunciation so I make sure that
I work on pronunciation from the very
beginning because once you develop that
habit it's just very difficult to get
rid of them later mm-hmm okay so you
work on pronunciation from the very
beginning yeah now it's going to be very
obvious that what people are going to
want to know is how are they going to be
how are they going to approach
pronunciation because I believe that
everyone out there what most people try
to pronounce the foreign language as
best as they can so they may try to
imitate they may try to you know listen
really really closely or you know read
up and descriptions of where they may
they should place their tongue etc etc
and but not many succeed at pronouncing
words like you do so how is it that you
produce you have any external tools or
what do you do well one thing that I do
all the time is to develop some kind of
sound mapping between the script and the
sounds of the language in Britain which
I make sure that my brain maps oh that
the correspondence between sounds and
script
so when you say map you mean that you're
having making sure you have this
connection between yes a connection you
know to develop a connection between how
and how they're written okay now some
people might say that it's better to go
for an only sound approach but I believe
that if you know how to develop this
just this bond it could be very
beneficial because sometimes it could be
confusing you know those sound mapping
because we are
we have our own language ingrained in
our system so we have a system that
might interference with the foreign
language but I believe that you know
developing this this sound mapping is
quite important this is the very first
thing that I do the second thing that a
that I do is I have what people call a
top-down approach and is that I start
with sentences and then I go for the so
called nuts and bolts which are the
details on how you pronounce in the word
so first of all I make sure they're mine
that I try I try to figure out patterns
in the language you know every language
has a as a series of patterns and how we
say things so I go for sentences first I
listen to how sentences sound and then I
go for pronunciation that is how we
produce sounds mechanically the single
words because a very important thing
that people are not aware I think most
people are not aware of is that even if
the pronunciation of words is always the
same in you know isolated words it
changes within within a sentence if you
say for example Roman is a great city
and then you say I want to go to role
you will notice that Rome at the
beginning of a sentence doesn't sound
exactly like Rome at the end of a
sentence they had it and that is for a
few reasons so I would first go and
that's how kids children learn a
language actually they hear bits and
pieces of a language but they don't hear
just isolated words the words live in a
context all the time mm-hmm and so we
need to make sure that we are acquiring
the way that we pronounce words in a
content
I'm always in a conference in fact this
is the sentence and then you know bigger
contest bigger picture is for the text
in which sentences are embedded so why I
find interesting is that so you look for
these patterns you know you find out how
the words are pronounced in the context
of a sentence some sort of flowing
speech and so are you then able to
extrapolate that pattern and apply it as
you want to or you know because that it
still seems to me and I'm gonna play
devil's advocate here it still seems to
me that it can be challenging because
you know I have known people that have
been study in English or another
language for years and they tried really
hard but they've not been able to so
what what are these people doing wrong
are they do they have problems
recognizing patterns or are they just
not doing it right what was it
I believe in training training training
means that if you are trained or
somebody trains you to figure out the
patterns then everything is gonna be
easier I have been training a countless
number of people in figuring out the
patterns in a few languages and I can
tell you that if you train them to hear
the sound and hear how the language
flows you know this distinctive to work
wonders means that people are not they
don't know how to do it they try been
trying it's not enough you have to know
how to do it okay and I believe if you
know the talent place plays a role in it
but I believe it everybody can figure it
out because sound and meaning sounded
syntax or entangled so we say things if
there is always a reason why we say
things in a certain way if you can point
that out and if you can tell it look we
say these things because we say and we
after these sounds there's there's a
reason to it people will say oh that's
and one of the very most important thing
is tell them how their first language
works if you show them how to you know
they're good at their their language so
they know they know how to work state if
you show them how it really works in Y
then they will understand it foreign
language howl at foreign language works
even better that's that's all the time
is it what's your native tongue and that
is a look your native tongue works like
this about it okay and so what sum up
some of the things you said you know to
develop great or better accent in a
foreign language you should pay
attention to the top-down approach so
how words on a house sentences are
uttered and then afterwards focus on the
details and because syntax and how you
pronounce things are related together so
you say things in a certain way to give
off a particular meaning yeah okay great
and so now I can't leave you there
I quietly with it and so you have to
give one or two tips that people out
there can use straight away to help them
improve their pronounce I'm putting on
this book improve their pronunciation -
tips - tips - I got - well let's let's
let's consider let's suppose that you're
the very first thing that I would do is
make sure that you choose a book which
shows for example some some important
features of language like rhythm and
stress I'm you know like words are
stressed they have a stress so a signal
for example has this system where they
show this
and make sure you are mapping sound
mapping the language make sure that you
understand the differences between how
you say something in in your language
and how you say something in another
language so let me just stop you right
there so this means paying a lot of
attention how things are compared to how
you are - in sound yeah so we're talking
about pain a lot of it cent pay a lot of
attention spend time on pronunciation
and intonation from the very beginning
okay so that's number one you know to
map your sounds you need to pay a lot of
attention to how the nature speaker is
speaking in this particular context to
convey the meaning bit using the
intonation of the language and so that's
tip number one pay a lot of attention to
how you were going to map with the sound
create that connection between meaning
and paying attention so as for listening
and reading is great but it's not enough
you have also to you also have to be a
little bit active and then the second
piece of advice that I would like to
give you is we're gonna be a big one
[Laughter]
record yourselves it means
sometimes we when we talk especially
when we talk if not when we leave
because let me read we have less things
to that our brain has to grapple cope
with but when we read something for
example we don't pay attention to how we
sounds some people say do I sound like
that you know they they don't realize it
so record yourself and then miss it to
yourself because when you listen to
yourself we have another perspective
mm-hmm possibly if you have a friend a
native speaker send it to send the file
to them and ask him how do I sound and
then they're going to point out the
things that you're not able to you know
figure out yourself and this follows the
principle and I remember I wrote an
article for your blog erm the four
universal laws of learning and one of
them was external feedback and so you
know putting your voice in some sort of
recording that you can then reflect upon
you're going to get yourself some
feedback that you can then use to
correct yourself you know if you could
say tweak yourself you know or calibrate
our brain we can figure out a lot of
patterns for ourselves but not all of
them and if you have a native speaker
helping you with the process you're
doing if you go out all the small
details that you couldn't figure out on
yourself because what I mean
a lot of language for example I do
remember that I used to the ng sound in
internment I've been pronouncing it
wrong for such a long time and then a
friend of mine said you pronouncing
along get like Lankenau de'longhi so
it's a different sound I hadn't picked
it up so she helping it and then I
practice it a little bit and then he
goes it's going for the nuts and bolts
only it's it's a refinement process you
have to put yourself you have to pay
attention but you also need something
external feedback it is so important
language learning some people say the
feedback is you know making being
corrected it's time for it and I think
it's one of the most important thing
that can happen to you and one of the
best things actually
okay so the last thing I'm gonna say is
there gonna be some people out there
listening think this sounds like a lot
of work it sounds like a lot of work you
know so it should is it going to take a
lot of work or or is it something that
is a lot of work where you just have to
do anyway what would you say it's about
but for the people who know the Pareto
principle but even for those who don't
know the Pareto principle if you work
hard on something at from the very
beginning then everything is gonna be
easier later so if you 20 20 20 percent
of your actions give you 80% of the
results
that's exactly how it works and that's
exactly how I've been developing
pronunciation never single languages
work so I love it so much it's so
complex well so so beautiful it's a
beautiful process of discovering a new
world and it's a sound world so to say
that it worked in the beginning I don't
consider homework I don't think if you
do it the right way you enjoy you don't
have to work that hard but to try to do
something every day like I don't know
could take a text every day try to read
it every day like five minutes try to
read it and record yourself you read it
twice then you record yourself you send
it to somebody you listen to yourself
you send it to somebody every single day
for maybe a month a month it's nothing
30 days then obviously there are some
languages where you have to work a
little bit harder in the case of Chinese
that's well that's all I did at the
beginning I was only working on
pronunciation
snoring sounds my father thought it was
crazy I knew you might have especially
with doing languages but it paid off and
now it's so easy my brain developed this
automatic patterns so I it's so easy to
after sentences I didn't work on it that
much just in three months maybe every
day a little bit 20 minutes not that
long so it's really not that complicated
and remember that if you do that if you
develop the right patterns at the
beginning and it's possible it's not
impossible
everybody's right then everything is
gonna be okay fantastic and then we have
you know our talk today on improving
your pronunciation in a foreign language
and so you know just to recap everything
that we have spoken about today
you know syntax and pronunciation are
linked together so the way you pronounce
things also gives off some meaning so
it's really important to pay attention
to the flow or the information of a
language and then we gave you two tips
today number one make sure that you pay
a lot of attention to how native
speakers and pronounce things in
particular context so that your brain
can map the sound the sounds and the
meaning is together and then make sure
that you were getting some external
feedback because this is going to be
extremely important for you to what I
would call calibrate yourself and make
sure that you are sounding better and
better as time goes on it's it's a
process that is incremental so you're
gonna make a little bit of progress
every single day and this is what you
need to do or some of the things that
you can do to stop sounding like a
native speaker and so thank you for
watching and we'll catch you in another
video right